So let' say I'm a proxy, and I want to put a key value pair in the coral DHT.
I'm going to use the key-based routing algorithm to place the key at an
appropriate node. What does that mean? Well, I'm
going to take the key, and even if I
have the node ID that is equal to this key, I'm not going to go to him directly.
Remember that, the Coral, key based routing algorithm
reducing the distance by half. So I'm going to
go to a node that is half the
distance to the desired destination. So the desired destination
is n. I'll go to a node that is half the distance, say n over two, n over
four, and so on, til I get to the desired destination. And as I'm going,
making these calls, saying that, well I'm
progressing towards this desired destination node, using that
key base routing algorithm that uses the XR
distance between the source of the destination halving
the distance at every step. What I'm going to ask is, are you loaded or full?
These two states that we talked about. And this guy says, no I'm not loaded or
full, and here is the next hop you can go to. So I keep going for, forward. And
if none of these guys say that they are loaded or full, I would
eventually reach my desired destination and place the key value over
there. However, when I do this hop, going
from hazardous to one fourth of this and so on, somebody along the way
may say that, look for this particular key
that you're trying to place. I'm already full, all
loaded, one of those two conditions is already
applying to me. So this node responds back to
me and says, I am either loaded, or full. If that is the response I get back,
then what I'm going to infer from the
response is that the rest of the distance going
toward the destination is all clogged up, because
of the tree saturation. And therefore, I'm not going
to even try to place the key value pair
at the destination, at the desire destination. And not
even at this guy because he's also loaded and
or full for the same key. And so I'm
going to retract my step and choose this node
as the node to place the key value pair.
So in other words, when I do a put operation,
there are two phases to it. The first phase is
the forward phase. In the forward phase, what we are
doing is, we are going to the guy that is half
the distance to the desired destination asking him are you
full or loaded. He says, no, I am not. Then
you go to the next guy who is even closer
to the desired destination. He says, he's not full or loaded.
Then you go to the next guy, who
is even closer. Using that, key based routing algorithm
that I described to you earlier. So keep
going till you hit a node, that is either
loaded or full. At that point you know,
you don't want to go any further towards the desired
destination because all of these guys are either loaded
or full, dealing with this particular key. And therefore,
the second phase of the algorithm that I'm
going to use, is retract my steps and go
back, and ensure that, that this guy is still
willing to host my key value pair. Why would
he change his mind? Well, between the time
that that I am making this forward motion it
is possible that this guy got either full or
loaded. So I'll recheck the condition. It says still
I'm good to host your key value pair,
I'll choose this node for the Put operation.
That's how the Coral Put operation works. So you can see that we are not storing
the key in the desired destination, which should
have been the way a greedy algorithm would
have worked. But in the sloppy algorithm of
Coral, we choose an appropriate node that is neither
full nor loaded, so that it can entertain requests for
retrieving this particular key value pair. So we've avoided the
meta server overload by doing this key-based
routing in the forward path during the put operation. So the get operation
is going to do exactly similarly. That is given a key that I'm looking
for, I'm not going to go directly to the destination that might be hosting it,
as would happen in the greedy approach. But instead, what I would do is go to a
node that it is half the distance to the key I'm looking for. And when I do
that, my hope is I'll find the key somewhere along the way. Because some guy may
be serving as the meta data server for that particular key. If
not, I will go, to the, destination. If nobody has retrieved
that key before, it will be available at the desired destination. I'll get it
from there. But the hope is that, if, a content is popular
enough, then, multiple people, multiple proxies
may have gotten the key value pair. And therefore, and they may have gotten the
key value pair, and in turn when they have gotten the content as well, they will
have put their own node IDs as a potential node for the content. And so, our
metadata server, when we are looking for a
particular key may not necessarily have to be
the destination which exactly matches that key.